Short and sweet, Hazara number two.
It is mutter lechachila, it is permissible to initially cook a par of food in a fleshik pot, in a meat pot, in order to serve it on a dairy dish, even while the food is hot, and that would go vice versa as well to the other situation where a person wants to cook something par in a dairy pot and serve it on a meat dish.
It's even permissible to use a dairy pot to heat up par of food which is cooked in a meat pot and vice versa.
It's also even permitted to mix two power foods which were cooked in two different pots.
You can have pasta that was cooked in a flasheek pot and vegetables that was cooked in a milheek pot.
Even if they're both benyomo, these two power foods which are no longer in the pots that they were cooked in can be mixed together l'chachila.
We discussed a situation where a person would fry a dovacharif, a sharp food, such as peppers or even onions, we discussed the possibility.
If a person would fry this dovacharif, this sharp food, in a meat or dairy pan.
So what would be the status of the Delver Charev? Because it has that sharpness. In a situation where the pan is a benyomo, of meat or dairy, everybody agrees, the Shulchan Aruch and Rama both agree that this food is either meat or dairy, whatever the pot was, and if it was mixed with the other type, it would be forbidden.
If the pot or the pan was Ein Oben Yomo, it has not been used in 24 hours, that's where we have a Machlokas, the Shulchan Aruch holds that the food is still considered Parv, even though it's sharp, because the pan is Ein Oben Yomo, while the Rama holds that, no, since the food is sharp, it does, it revives the flavor that's inside of the keli, inside of the utensil, and it is considered either meat or dairy, whatever the pan was, and if it's mixed with the other type, it would be forbidden.
We then had a discussion of what situations would qualify as a not-bar-not.
So in a situation where a food, either meat or dairy, was cooked in a pot, and then cleaned out, and then a par of food was subsequently cooked in that pot,
that is a situation where all post-kim all agree that the second food is considered a not-bar-not,
because the flavor went from food to the pot, and then from the pot to another food, and since there was a pot in the middle,
The flavor was decreased, it was diminished by being inside the pot, and the par of food, the third food, sorry, the second food is now considered a not-branat.
Where we had a machlokas is two other situations where there was not a pot in the middle, either the flavor went from one food to another food to a pot, or from one food to another food to another food, that was where we had a machlokas.
In the different opinions, there are those who held that that is not considered a not-branat because there is no pot in the middle, there are those who held that it is a not-branat because at least there is a pot somewhere.
And there are those who held that even if there's no pot at all, you can still be considered a Nat Bar Nat because the flavor ultimately does get passed on from one food to the next to the next, which is two steps away from the original food.
We then discussed the Nat Bar Nat Bishas Bishel, which was in a situation where a food is now going to transfer its flavor into a pot, and then the pot will give its flavor to another food, but it will all happen simultaneously.
Simultaneously, it will all take place while the pot is on the fire.
So one example we gave is, let's say, milk splashes on the outside of a pot, and inside the pot there is pasta.
So since, although the milk hits the pot and then goes from the pot to the water or to the pasta inside of the pot,
because it all takes place while the food is on the fire, maybe perhaps we would say that the flavor does not have a chance to get degraded yet,
and it goes straight into the food inside of the pot and basically kind of goes right through the pot
without stopping it without getting degraded another example was a more common example perhaps
is using a sous vide so if you have meat inside of a bag and then the bag inside is of water and
the water is inside of a bucket so potentially we would say that the bucket can be considered
already a not by not because the flavor goes from the meat to the bag to the bucket or potentially
Shas Bishol,
Sorry, if a person wanted to know what's the status of the sous vide itself, the actual heating element, this would be the same discussion, because the meat inside the bag can now go through, the flavor of the meat can go through the bag, into the water, and then into the sous vide itself, the actual heating element, and make it flesheks, while according to the Beis Ephraim, it would stay parv.
What do we do?
L'maisah, L'ashkenazim, hold L'chachila, we should follow the Chavas Daas, and L'chachila would consider the suvi, or the bucket that's holding the water, to be fleshicks,
while the Sephardim hold L'chachila, we can follow the Beis Ephraim, and it's not a problem.
Even the Ashkenazim would B'dievet, rely on the Beis Ephraim, and B'dievet, in a situation where, let's say, the suvi was used to cook meat, which is inside of a bag,
and then it was used to cook something dairy inside of a bag, B'dievet, the Ashkenazim, would allow that food,
And we would rely on the Beis Ephraim B'dievet.
We mentioned once again that Nat Bar Nat does not apply to things that are inherently prohibited.
It only applies to Basav HaChalef.
However, Rav Ovadya did add that in a situation of great need, a person can rely on Te'imas Akim.
A person can rely on a non-Jew tasting a food which was cooked inside of a utensil, which was inherently forbidden.
And they could be trusted to say that there's no flavor from the forbidden food.
The example we gave was by the peas, if a person has canned peas or canned corn, without a heksher.
So if they're in a real bind, a Sfardi can rely on this and ask a non-Jew,
Besir Fituma, without giving any details, but can ask him,
do you taste anything like pig or anything other than corn?
And to find out if it's actually forbidden, this was something that a Sfardi can rely on.
However, Ashkenazim do not have this allowance.
We then discussed a very classic case where a challah was placed on top of a challah pot
Chalent was cooking, and obviously there's meat inside of the Chalent, so we were wondering what is the status of this challah? Is the challah parv, or is it fleshek? Well, this would be a case of Nat B'Shash B'Shel, if assuming that the challah was directly contacting the lid, so the meat is giving flavor directly to the lid, and the lid could be giving flavor to the bread, but because it's during cooking, fleshek goes right through, the fleshek flavor goes right through the lid into the challah.
So this will be dependent on the Malchokas between the Chavas Daas and the Beis Ephraim.
The Chavas Daas holding that the bread on the lid is now Fleshix, while the Beis Ephraim would say, no, the bread is still Parv, it's considered a Nat Bar Nat of Fleshix.
At least for the Eved, it would be for Ashkenazim, if a person put cheese on it, it would be okay.
And if it were into the Mechaber, you'd be able to put cheese on it, the Chachila, according to the Beis Ephraim.
That's all assuming that the bread is directly on the pot.
But if a person would put a piece of tinfoil between the Chala and the Chalom Pot, that would be amazing.
That would be much better because that would be a case of shtei kederos, of two utensils touching each other, which we say flavored snago without rota, without any liquid.
And therefore, if according to everybody, if a person would wrap the challah in tinfoil, of course, leaving it a little open, maybe to get out of hatamana issues for Shabbos.
But if a person would put tinfoil between the chalampat and the challah, that would keep the bread par of according to everybody.
And lastly, we said that a person must always be sure to make sure that canned foods do have a good heksher,
because without that, there is a very great concern that they pasteurize the cans with non-kosher water,
and that would make the food non-kosher, because it would be a not-ber-not issue with something inherently problematic,
which we say is forbidden.